c'est un projet que n'aurait pas renié
les pharaons pourtant le méga barrages
construits en ethiopie sur le nil bleu
principal affluent du nil suscite
l'inquiétude de l'egypte et du soudan
les deux pays situés en aval du fleuve
craignent de voir leur approvisionnement
en eau soumis au bon vouloir d'addis
abeba une question vitale puisque le nil
représente par exemple 80 17% de
l'approvisionnement en eau potable de
l'egypte objectif des deux pays impactés
par ce projet entamé en 2011
obtenir un accord contraignant sur la
gestion du barrage les deux parties ont
discuté du projet de barrage éthiopien
renaissance et il a été souligné qu'il
est nécessaire de négocier un accord
contraignant sur le remplissage et
l'exploitation du barrage d'une manière
qui préserve les droits et les intérêts
des trois pays
neuf des propositions pour l'instant
refusée par l'ethiopie le grand barrage
pour la renaissance c'est son nom est
une fierté nationale dans un pays miné
par les divisions ethniques et les
fractures politiques
ce colosse de béton de 145 mètres de
haut doit devenir la plus grande
installation hydroélectrique d'afrique
et fournir de l'électricité à tous ses
habitants
alors que près de la moitié en sont
privés aujourd'hui si les négociations
patinent
les trois partis reste pourtant
optimiste récemment l'ethiopie a même
fait quelques concessions
les divergences sur les aspects
techniques se sont atténuées au cours de
la tripartite l'ethiopie pour remplir le
barrage en trois ans grâce à une saison
des pluies de cette ampleur il est très
facile pour l'ethiopie de le remplir
instantanément mais compte tenu du
véritable intérêt de l'ethiopie à
répondre aux préoccupations des pays en
aval à savoir l'egypte et le soudan
nous sommes prêts à prolonger le
remplissage de 4 à 7 ans chapeauté par
l'union africaine les négociations
s'annoncent difficiles
l'ethiopie vient d'annoncer avoir
atteint un niveau de remplissage
suffisant pour faire fonctionner les
premières turbines du barrage
un passage en force qui risque de
froisser davantage ses voisins l'analyse
de marc lavergne et les directeur de
recherche au cnrs
c'est un problème technique qui devait
être gêné je dirige est réglée par des
techniciens avec des diplomates bien sûr
mais qui na qui doit aboutir à ce que
l'intérêt général préval qu'est ce que
ces trois pays seront toujours riverains
et voisins et sont condamnés à
travailler ensemble
aucune guerre aucune crise aucun bras de
fer ne peut régler ce problème dans
l'intérêt général des trois pays qui
sont aussi le développement de
l'ethiopie
c'est la production d'électricité qui va
profiter à toute la région donc l'egypte
elle se bat un petit peu à mes yeux le
dos au mur avec une sorte de mauvais
procès et si maintenant on entre donne
des négociations plus longue qui
permettent de mettre sur pied un accord
durable équitable
et bien c'est très bien mais le barrage
de toutes façons de va se faire va se
remplir va produire de l'électricité que
les pays d'aval le veuille ou non